et puisque nous en sommes à la poire
passons nos confrères mage et plus
précisément au camembert lors du
concours du plus gros mangeur de ce
produit le jeu est simple il faut manger
le plus possible de camembert en un
quart d'heure et pour seules armes dans
ce combat une bouteille de cidre
peu importe la manière il faut enfourner
un jeu de marie harel la créatrice du
camembert n'aurait certes pas désavoué
pour la petite histoire sachez que c'est
un certain maurice ronet pour l'acteur
un autre qui a gagné ce concours
en un quart d'heure il a avalé trois
camembert trois cas monsieur rooney est
du reste un habitué de ce genre de
concours si l'on en juge par son
palmarès plus gros mangeur de boudin à
mortagne de kilos trip à longny au
perche 31,9 du rabroue 29 crêpes à
nogent-le-rotrou 33 banane je ne sais
plus où 318 escargots un solide appétit
quoi et à monsieur qui doit s'étonner
parfois le matin d'avoir l'estomac dans
les talons
[Musique]